Democrats can run but they can't hide
from their party's history of obnoxious
defund the police rhetoric take
democratic congresswoman Angie Craig
she's calling for a Crackdown on crime
violent crime after becoming a victim of
one herself the congresswoman who
represents parts of Minnesota surviving
a vicious attack after some lowlife
assaulted her in the elevator of her
Washington DC apartment thankfully cops
nabbed the guy watch this I think we
have to think about how in the world can
we make sure that we're not just letting
criminals out I mean it wasn't even in
every instance that he got 10 days or 30
days many times the charges were
completely dropped before any justice
was achieved at all if you throw
somebody in jail for 10 days and think
you know there's your punishment and
we're gonna let you right back on the
street what the hell do you think is
going to happen I mean she's been great
after during the incident she was very
brave heroic almost and uh you know I
like what what she did but critics are
now pointing out that the
congresswoman's ties to the defund the
police movement you know really make it
sound hypocritical one of her top
staffers spoke out against law
enforcement for example during the
George Floyd riots one tweet from the
staffer saying quote fund counselors not
cops also the counselor judge tweeted
burn it all down I mean
Byrne Liz Young the the aid to
Congressman Craig so you know no one
likes cops until you need one well you
know I'm tired of fighting this defund
the police nonsense so for years the
Democrats have been about social justice
we watch it we talk about it but these
these Congress people they don't
represent you they don't feel your pain
they're not worried about you they don't
listen to or read about the reality of
what's happening to America and so I
have a great idea and I think that idea
is if you want to defund the police
we'll notify 9-1-1 whenever you call him
you don't get the police if you want to
defund the police police will tell the
PD Dispatch you don't go to that
person's address you know that if that's
what they want that's what they should
get but now that the congresswoman has
been victimized now she feels your pain
nonsense less than two weeks ago we
talked about DC wanting to lower
penalties for violent crime I didn't
hear this congresswoman say oh no I'm
against that and for those who say at
least now she's on our side baloney the
police have been demoralized
resignations and people retiring are up
you can't even recruit anymore you've
done your damage stick with it deep on
the police as it relates to you now go
on your way okay thank you judge uh you
know once you uh comment in the in the
way that uh some of the left has come
have commented over the overtime uh
defund the police does that then
foreclose you from ever speaking out or
can you be converted as the
congresswoman obviously was and say you
know I see the light
I could converter
and the judge has a new policy
apparently if you refer to fund the
police you don't get to call the police
they have to call 912 and the obvious
point is that she is a hypocrite who is
the victim of her own policies but
there's a large report Geraldo okay the
congresswoman needs to live in a nicer
building
I'm not victim blaming but this is the
obvious point she's a congresswoman and
has plenty of money I looked up at her
net worth she's living in a violent city
Washington DC and she doesn't live in a
doorman building someone let this guy
he's a mentally ill homeless guy who was
defecating outside led him into the
building and then he just socks her in
the jaw she's got a great chin and she
also used a lot of smarts by throwing
the coffee I want to see the
surveillance footage from the camera in
the elevator that I'd like to see but
you got to live a little bit safer than
that and a lot of people can't afford
Dorman building she should be able to
that's the solution for people in
government is that they get to be safe
see while they're while their citizens
aren't I didn't make the obvious point
because I've made that thousands of
times on this show I'm trying to make a
larger point but I don't know if that
was larger Dana wasn't it for all that
well isn't it admirable the way she
fought the guy with the hot coffee so
she should but no I mean it was terrible
but no citizen of the my daughter lives
country
should have to use their scalding coffee
to ward off an intruder into their
building and someone who's going to
assault them on their way to the office
that's just yep that's unacceptable and
the thing that the DC city council is
doing right now is even worse but
they're trying to basically lower
penalties for carjackings today there
was a big they were supposed to clear
out a homeless Park
um right it's right by the White House
McPherson Square and there was a big but
don't don't you can't do that don't
clear this out and there's government
officials uh you know city workers in
hazmat suits cleaning up that part this
is our nation's capital it literally is
a stone's throw from the White House
this guy was as Greg pointed out to me
he wasn't con to be considered homeless
he was experiencing homelessness so
we're even watering down that and the
D.C city council wants to give everyone
a jury trial even for a misdemeanor so
it'll swamp the courts and then nobody
will be able to get Justice and people
will just want to leave the other thing
about this is remember Corey Bush the
congresswoman from St Louis she has
private security yeah right so she uses
campaign donations to pay for private
security for herself that also doesn't
sound like a good solution for anybody
and Cory bush is also for defund the
police last point is Greg's brought up
before the anchors from another Network
that went to dinner during the crime
it's free and said everything's fine
everything looks we don't see a problem
here it's the victims that they don't
ever talk about especially like the ones
here in New York where you never see AOC
or anybody talk about them they never
say they never have a word to say about
them they just want to go after Maga
Republicans it's pretty infuriating but
isn't this great the way things get
changed you know you have a high profile
case like this maybe the where obviously
security screams the the need you know
for these residents isn't that how the
Washington DC city council sees the
light eventually if they possibly can
unfortunately I mean that's maybe what
it takes first of all I do believe that
she had already voted in favor of the
resolution before this so she was she
was she was supporting the disapproval
uh the resolution of disapproval to
block uh the revised criminal code
because I remember she I remember when
we talked about this she was upset that
her colleagues were still doing this
we're still going through with this
voting to protect this soft on crime
bill that allowed creeps like the ones
that attacked her to roam free uh to
your point Geraldo it's off we brought
we talked about this when other when the
border states were busting migrants to
the doorsteps of liberal Elites uh that
married uh Progressive policies to their
consequences and I sat here and I said
there has to be a way maybe you bust
criminals to their uh um to their
location or maybe you do like prevent
them from using 9-1-1 but unfortunately
this is what it takes in some cases is
that the people that are that represent
citizens get the taste of what the
citizens or experiences this may be the
only way to convince liberals they're
wrong on crime and it's one mugging at a
time I can't remember who said it I
don't know if it was PJ or work or
somebody before him said a conservative
is a liberal who was mugged by reality
it should just be a conservative is a
liberal who was mugged because that's
what it's coming down to
with all that said the fact of the
matter is this guy was arrested
for 12 assaults in the year before this
happened he had 25 bench warrants this
is an utter failure of the criminal
justice system in our nation's capital
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else